security forces in myanmar have
reportedly opened fire on medical
workers who were taking part in a
pro-democracy protest
in the city of mandalay hundreds of
people have been killed
many more injured since a military coup
in february
overthrew the elected government this
week marks the myanmar's traditional new
year festival but
instead of celebrating many continue to
protest
they should be celebrating the new year
festival of tejan
instead they're marching against a coo
a coup that saw the overthrow of their
elected leader
chi and replaced her with a military
dictatorship
across myanmar protesters holding
flowers
are using this week as a rallying cry
but they know the risks security forces
roam the streets descent is quickly
and brutally stamped out
just ask these people in current state
forced into hiding in caves after the
military junta
carried out airstrikes in their region
the military seems intent on
intensifying its pitiless policy of
violence
against the people of myanmar using
military-grade and indiscriminate
weaponry
more than 700 people have died since
february according to a local monitoring
group
but that hasn't stopped the protesters
as they continue
their fight for freedom
now there have been calls for countries
like china to hold the
military junta and myanmar accountable
let's get more on that angle you can see
standing by to share his expertise with
us is abraham
schneider he is a professor of chinese
politics and international relations
at the fu university in berlin welcome
to the program
thanks for joining us walk us through
the chinese response
good morning welcome walk us through the
chinese response to this coup
and how it has potentially been
impacting the situation on the ground
where
we've been seeing the violence
escalating
well this is a merciless regime quite
obviously and it
it belongs to a group of chinese quote
unquote allies like for example north
korea
but certainly also including the myanmar
military
about which china is not really happy
china's interest is not
seeing a military coup being restored in
myanmar
don't forget the chinese government has
also been cooperating with the
democratically elected
government of aung san chuchi quite
intensively indeed china's interest is
not establishing a certain
type of political system in myanmar but
having
an overall political system in place
because
myanmar is a core country in china's
geostrategic interest
it is the transit country between the
indian ocean
and the southwestern chinese province of
yunnan
it could be extremely important as a
transit country should something
like we have seen it happening in the
sewers canal
happened in the very sensitive area of
the malacca strait
in that case china needs stability in
the political system
in order to use myanmar as a transit
corridor
for oil gas resources even for trade
so it's not about the domestic situation
in myanmar
predominantly but certainly about the
geostrategic position of the country
so ultimately it's all about economic
interest is that is that what it is
it is economic interest it is geostating
interest
china has investing been investing
extremely intensively in myanmar in
railways
in streets in pipelines in deep sea
ports
there is also a geostrategic element for
china's
ever stronger navy moving around the
indian ocean
and having deep supports in myanmar
available
so it's a whole spectrum of geostrategic
interests
tell us because you know we we've seen
you know others in the international
community community
condemning the moves by uh the military
in myanmar as the death toll there is
rising
the u.s and the uk have imposed economic
sanctions on the country
um how do you see this now sort of
shaking out going forward because you
know we have some countries that are
trying to put pressure
on the country and then others um
that that that that you know seem to
still be embracing it for example like
china
is this basically driving myanmar into
china's arms
well myanmar is in china's arms even
without this this
military coup it would be closely
connected
uh to china but the problem is what else
could we do
we could condemn it we could establish
sanctions but this leads us to this old
and familiar debate about sanctions
sanctions do have effects i guess but
most of the time
as we can see in russia and in many
other cases they do not have the
intended effects
they are created for so i would have my
doubts whether strong words from western
countries
even military economic sanctions would
really
change the behavior of this brutal
military regime
in the end it will be up to the people
in myanmar they take the courage
to do the streets they risk their lives
they don't need
only strong words they would need
anything else
but this is what we do not supply to
them
they are getting rhetoric support
but that's it in the end that has been
the case in the past and we'll
unfortunately it will happen this time
as well so many of them have already
given their lives given their lives to
the cause of democracy given their their
their lives to
the hope for for freedom in the country
um
what do you make of what's going on is
there any hope
for the citizens or do they not stand a
chance against the military
well uh we can only applaud these people
who have the courage to to enter the
streets each and every day
again knowing what they're risking their
lives
but they are doing it they are fed up
with military government in other words
and all we can do is give them any
support
we could master but as i said there's
little we can do from
from outside it is up to them and we can
only hope and support them
that they might in the end be successful
in sweeping away a military regime
and re-establishing a democratically
elected government
the race is open and as i said china
will certainly be reluctant
to condemn this military coup for for
a different reason china is reluctant to
accept external uh interference in its
own affairs
so it is also reluctant to establish
this interference in other cases
as well china will be silent china will
be watching and following his own
interests but the world community
can only hope that these encourager
couches people in myanmar in the end
will prevail
and hope indeed they do we thank you so
much for joining us eberhard san
schneider professor of chinese politics
and international
relations at fu university in berlin
my pleasure thank you